des questions et trois invités sur ce
plateau pour y répondre Laurence Farin
député MoDem député européenne moderne
vous êtes aussi béarnaise et conseillère
régionale bonjour Merci bonjour les
sauces au plateau on se dimanche en
politique donc l'actualité évidemment de
la semaine marqué peut-être parce qu'on
peut considérer comme le baroud
d'honneur des manifestants contre la
réforme des retraites Laurence Farin à
la première question et pour vous député
européenne modem oui mais issu quand
même de la majorité de ce pays en tout
cas c'est comme ça que vous étiez
présenté l'an dernier il y a 4 ans
élections européennes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur cette
dernière journée ou en tout cas sur
cette encore énième journée de
mobilisation
sociaux l'ont dit c'est on va passer à
une autre phase et je crois qu'il est
temps les derniers baroud d'honneur à
l'Assemblée montrent que
la question est fermée sur l'âge de
départ mais pas sur tout le reste parce
que je tiens à dire que sur ce sujet ou
mon mouvement politique là on est
vraiment sur des questions
intérieures a été très
parfois critique quand il a appelé à
plus de négociations de concertation
pourquoi pas un référendum pour toujours
mieux expliquer et associer les français
mais aussi sur des points clés comme
celui de la pénibilité du travail des
femmes de la clause de revoyeur qui
était des sujets importants donc
aujourd'hui oui cette loi est passée
elle est les premiers décrets arrivent
il y a une autre question qui va être
très importante c'est la question du
travail et c'est une deuxième phase
qu'il faut aborder avec les partenaires
sociaux qui vont être reçus à l'Élysée à
Matignon pour maintenant rentrer dans
les détails de ce que doit être la vie
au travail aujourd'hui
cette semaine comme depuis un an et demi
il y a le conflit en Ukraine et la
guerre d'ailleurs on va appeler ça comme
ça en Ukraine Laurence pharin le chef de
l'État français souhaite l'élargissement
de l'Union européenne c'est encore
prononcé ces derniers jours notamment
pour intégrer l'Ukraine et peut-être
aussi la Moldavie quelle est votre
position là-dessus à vous en tant que
député européenne sur l'Ukraine je veux
dire qu'on a une solidarité au premier
jour du conflit que cette solidarité
elle a été très fortement portée par la
France je rappelle qu'à l'époque on
était pendant la présidence française de
l'Union européenne donc Emmanuel Macron
a joué un rôle de tout premier plan pour
mettre autour de la table tous les
acteurs et dire et prendre des décisions
très difficiles comme celles qui
concernait le gaz et le pétrole russe et
notamment avec nos voisins allemands
donc cette solidarité elle a été sans
faille tout au long du dispositif elle
crée des fractures dans les partis
politiques parce qu'en effet on voit
très bien que nos deux parties extrêmes
RN LFI nups et surtout LFI sont tout à
fait contre tout ce qu'on a fait et sont
absolument opposés à la solidarité avec
le crâne parce qu'ils ont ce tropisme
pro russe
donc quand Emmanuel Macron dit je veux
élargir l'Europe ben oui c'est une
nécessité c'est une nécessité alors on
est confronté à un
la guerre le retour de la guerre et ce
cet élargissement il est pas si simple
alors oui on a donné un statut de
candidat accéléré à l'Ukraine et il y a
une autre démarche qui est faite donc
c'est un statut de candidat c'est une
accélération mais pour autant il faut
que l'Ukraine se mette en conformité
avec nos valeurs européennes et notre
fonctionnement européen dans le même
temps il a créé la communauté politique
européenne qui s'est réunie il y a je
crois la semaine dernière donc en
Moldavie pays éminemment pro-européen
qui veut nous rejoindre parce que aussi
ils ont cette question de protection et
pourquoi parce que il faut un bloc
solide face ou aux attaques russes face
à la question chinoise face à ce qui
peut arriver de nord-américain voilà
donc c'est pas un élargissement pour un
élargissement c'est un bloc cohérent et
aujourd'hui ce Paris est réussi avec la
communauté politique la deuxième partie
de ce dimanche en politique on va
évoquer un peu plus près d'un peu plus
près le scrutin européen dans un an la
première question est pour vous Madame
Farin ça va se dérouler du 6 au 9 juin
2024 exactement est-ce que c'est on
attend un enseignement national ou
européen
de ce scrutin européen
et attirer des leçons de résultats
électoraux européens et c'est vrai que
dans les baromètres qu'on a les Français
sont pas les plus intéressés ne sont pas
les plus concernés mais il faut que le
débat s'installe et c'est tout le rôle
d'une campagne on l'a vu en 2019 on
pensait en se disait bon désaffections
ce sera un passage obligé or il y a eu
un sursaut de participation et pourquoi
plus 5 points et 10% à y voir 12 14 chez
les plus jeunes pourquoi parce que au
cœur des préoccupations il y avait la
préoccupation climatique qui reste qui
demeure aujourd'hui comment l'a dit
l'Europe est renvoyé à sa raison d'être
avec le retour de la guerre et il y aura
beaucoup de débats parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de clivages dans la classe
politique peut-être qu'on y reviendra
qui vont donner matière aux Français
pour se déterminer et pour savoir qu'il
est important d'aller s'exprimer ce
jour-là particulièrement Laurence
c'était dans les dans les résultats des
élections en 2019 que l'Europe ne
mobilise pas forcément les électeurs
est-ce que c'est une erreur en tout cas
en France oui comme je l'ai dit il y a
des enjeux qui sont clairs et des
positions politiques qui sont pas assez
bien du côté des politiques ou pas pour
faire comprendre aux gens qu'il faut
voter pour ces élections européennes qui
a beaucoup de dossiers de la campagne et
je crois qu'il y aura une campagne
encore une fois sur des points très
climant on a des parties pro-européens
et des parties qu'ils sont moins et des
parties compensées être pour européens
type LR qui sont en train de se déclarer
dans le cadre de la migration pour
revoir la primauté du droit européen ça
veut dire devenir des frexiters dans le
même temps on voit très bien que le RN
rejette complètement la politique que
nous adoptons sur l'Ukraine que au
Parlement européen et on dévoilera leur
vote ils sont complètement antisociaux
puisqu'il rejette tous ces votes qui
rejettent tous les droits votent sur les
droits des femmes elle est fit de la
même manière jouer une partition
dangereuse comme vous dites il y a un
manque de cohérence à l'Europe on sait
pas trop il y a une partie du PS qui
voudrait épaisse l'autre nom mais
profondément dans les gènes européens on
peut se poser des questions
il y a un mouvement qui est pro-européen
sans aucune ambiguïté c'est celui la
majorité Président
je pense qu'il y a un temps pour tout
dans les débats merci de nous inviter
aujourd'hui parce que c'est rare qu'on
puisse parler d'Europe il y a sans doute
un déficit dans les médias il y a un
temps pour tout parler dans les médias
et ce temps viendra je crois que je
lisais un sondage dans rostade ou 77%
des Français se disent satisfait de
l'action de l'Europe sur l'Ukraine donc
s'ils veulent continuer il faut le
continuer avec des parties pro-européens
parce qu'on voit que dans le même temps
en Europe de plus en plus de parties
anti-européens progressent la droite
alliée à l'extrême droite progresse à
peu près partout on est dans cette phase
donc ça veut dire que 2024 avec un
parlementier Européen ça pose vraiment
des questions ça remet en question toute
la politique climatique toute la
politique de souveraineté la lutte
contre ce qui se passe la lutte
d'agression de Vladimir Poutine et
autres donc
[Musique]
mais notamment vous avez interpellé sur
ce sujet sur le cyber alors évidemment
pas propre à l'Aquitaine mais en général
vous êtes vous demander une stratégie
européenne forte on parlait de pêche on
parlait de quota quel peut être cette
stratégie européenne forte en matière de
cyber-harcèlement contre les jeunes en
général alors déjà aujourd'hui on s'est
doté de la première réglementation
mondiale sur les plateformes numériques
ça s'appelle le l'acte pour les services
numériques et c'est une première au
monde et ce texte très ambitieux il a
décidé de poser des règles et de donner
des responsabilités à Facebook
tous les géants Twitter machin tous les
endroits où le cyber-harcèlement lieu
alors il y a pas en fait ils sont
maintenant responsables de tous les
contenus illégaux et illicite
pas c'est à dire que ces géant c'est
géant et ces gens vivaient dans un
désert réglementaire absolu l'Europe a
tapé du point sur la terre
c'est comme si un propriétaire de
journal n'était pas responsable c'est le
prix qui était imprimé dedans donc à
partir de 25 août puisque la loi sera
appliquée le 25 août elle a été débattue
négocié et appliqué dans un mandat
européen je trouve que c'est quand même
une victoire géniale donc ils seront
responsables ça veut dire que ça
touchera en partie la question des
propos
agressifs et de tous les conséquences
que ça peut avoir
quand on en arrive au suicide on a tous
les tous les noms en tête de de l'Insee
etc enfin des choses horribles ça existe
au plan européen donc aujourd'hui
commencer que ça va aller toujours plus
loin que on a ces questions de Deep fake
d'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle etc etc il faut aller plus
loin dans cette règle et donc c'est pour
ça que au nom de la protection de
l'enfance au nom de la protection des
mineurs nous continuons à avancer sur ce
sujet